hello there reject nation if you haven't
seen our Avengers story trailer reaction
you know the MODOK threat go check that
out as promised so we're gonna cover the
gameplay now this is coming from
GameSpot Marvel's Avengers full war
table gameplay reveal event
yeah it's 25 minutes long let's just
swinging action and see what's up I did
want to mention again that I'm playing
The Last of Us to start it up super late
last night periodically I'm going to be
posting videos on Twitter share
reactions and thoughts and feelings
through it eventually a YouTube video
follow me on Twitter in the meantime
let's do this we'll be skipping the
story trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
project offers a world protected by
science Tarleton a victim l8a himself
uses Ames technological light and the
public sphere than humans to convince
the world but the superpower are
uncontrollable o be trusted
he's deranged obsession to become MODOK
mental organism designed only for
killing when choosing a villain we knew
we needed someone with a muscle and
mental capacity to become an abundance
level threat we also wanted a new face
for modern Avengers fans
[Music]
girl finding a cure and she believes
George Darlington was behind the plot to
discredit the Avengers and she has proof
as you pick up the trail of the long
disbanded Avengers you'll advance the
story of the single-player campaign
unlocking more and more hero specific
missions we know you've been asking for
new gameplay that's not formated we hear
you so here's a place don't sound so
upset yeah we hear you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
looks like he just saved the day
was uh Christine ever heard from Ironman
one he wanted him to move like Kratos
yes
[Music]
sounds kinda like Peter Lorre lucky
Peter look the style does kind of it
does remind me of Kratos
[Music]
well done Thor now only ten more of
those to go
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
does it think that Maria Nellie's uncle
or that black boy a lot of his black
widow vert it could be the cool feels
Maria Hill must be black right up
yeah now I want to play as Mario
and discern some voices yet
[Music]
it's just like watching someone play a
video game hole punching nothing in the
background yeah there he goes yeah
almost crushed
[Music]
cap is my boy I mean the birth or this
[ __ ] hey really is it making me want
that hammer
I hope throughout the game you just get
to dress him in different t-shirts nice
yeah how
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah yeah way to go hope you did
something
ha
it's like pull off the word gameplay
here yeah
hee hee
[Music]
and just looks like a mocap actor
Marsha's is lightning thunder and
thunder strike and everything
[Music]
good legs spread wide open ready yeah
and you keep striking lightning on time
[Music]
I'm leaving oh that's cool or help and
you can do that I just don't like his
face it's not because it's not exactly
Chris Hemsworth's face no John that it
is what it is a hundred percent well
that was what most become this
I never said that you guys assumed once
the debenture is a great example of a
hero mission a single-player campaign
experience focusing on a specific
playable character or hero missions give
us a chance to tell more of each hero
story and showcase the variety depth of
our hero designs let's take a quick look
at how Thor plays with the combat
systems together combos attacks from a
few some earlier to pin and ease from a
distance
[Music]
[Music]
he knows our personally
it's cool off TV play for example for
support any progression so why is all
this important because it means you're
Thor will play differently than my Thor
and my walk will be different than yours
my hook is going to be passive crate a
confrontation or customization when you
have gear equipped it grants a bonus
damage modifier and change the emissive
color of your attack different paths to
the Commission's iron I attend that
always go plastic or top blade which is
a nod to an alias the way I first
appeared in 1962 s journey into mystery
issue 83 bertoni's start tech Allison
that was inspired by the bleeding edge
armor that first appeared in invincible
Iron Man number 25 in 2010 while there a
ton about things you learn just by
playing some will require completing
iconic mission chains to earn each
hero's iconic outfit
and some outfits will only be available
in our online marketplace they say
customize the attitude yes oh yeah
you're heroes okay
I think it's time for another trailer
first look at how all that customization
is especially fun when you play together
this is
[Music]
oh did he absorb that lightning there
yeah
[Music]
you can't rebuild the Helicarrier
[Music]
[Music]
Australia
[Music]
come on the Kamikaze all fear
is a game looks like a lot of fun how
often you could alternate
like between characters shoes always my
shinzaemon is in customization it'd be
cool if you could switch around more is
a middle point Afghanistan Iraq 1942
sure yeah classic wars with your heroes
whether playing he relations or war
zones
you always make forward progress with
your heroes by your Helicarrier you'll
use the wort able to launch missions but
the variety of objectives and challenges
if you guys go on the co-op trailer each
mission is grounded in story so whether
you're in the campaign or war zones
you're always working together to stop
aim and rebuild the resistance you get
new shoes new Jarvis Maria Hill hit pair
and more characters from oral history
[Music]
once you think your mission you aboard
the Quinjet for you to matchmake switch
heroes choose your loadout and of course
pick the right look and attitude for the
job we as you start playing missions
across the globe you realize aims
entrench themselves and seize
patience of life all in the name of
research more salts range from wide-open
spaces for exploration interiors with
variety of grades do just that as you
progress through the campaign you'll
also be rebuilding and upgrading the
chimera your Helicarrier which is you
own flying bass that's the part on the
most Lincoln's already include lean
maintenance five years since to fight
the first Oregon orangie pen and have
powers some former shield agents who
refused to pledge allegiance to aim and
some just want to help
you'll join their cause in the feel our
hip logo in the back ashes like the
human alliance and shield ages ha dum
dum - Kim you deserve more than one
movie there will always be so you want
to ensure your Avengers are ready for
anything we're gonna talk a lot during
the game - I'm only gonna talk about the
criticisms after this that's just the
beginning this is original Avengers
single-player story I wanna tease of one
of the boss fighters you completed your
friends grows we add new heroes
[Music]
thank you for following us and believing
in us come on give a big shock on our
community thank you for caring and
telling us what you think
of course listening and its fans
ourselves we're all working every day to
make marvel's avengers worthy of your
support I get it please stick around
after the show to ask questions and chat
stay after my birthday dude say it John
happy bird no since Saint this thing you
always say and I want something I know
it's against you for your birthday yeah
you said it you said the thing I said
the thing I brought the thing such a
dum-dum Dugan dummy dude Dugan dumb that
guy played him bison and Street Fighter
The Legend of chun-li oh just racking up
those great roles any time I pull out a
notepad I go huh
didn't really need my notepad I should I
have my notepad it's like a placebo
effect or something suddenly oh my let
me just keep it in your breast pocket at
all times in case you should get shot
yeah I actually thought that looked like
a total blast I look like a lot a lot of
fun I'm excited for it the couple of
concerns that I did have even though you
get the variety and the range comes from
switching around to different players
and it looks like all that is all
specifically tailored you know everyone
feels like they'll garner a different
experience per individual that you're
playing as the reason I was saying I
want to see a bit of a boss level fight
you know like a game is only rewarding
when it feels challenging and all the
f-m up abilities that you got and all
the upgrades you can eventually earn it
all looks like a total blast I can't
have besides that enough it really looks
like a blast it also looked like it was
really easy to do all this and if I like
it could get repetitive after a rock
that's everything every game takes a
look quite a few hours to play right
yeah and after a while you're like you
know you need to mix up the challenges
but I know there's only so much you
could do even with upgrading the amount
of moves and powers you can have you
need to mix up the
and granted they're trying to cover a
lot in here and I totally get that
they're trying to cover a whole bunch in
this trailer but that is just my one
little concern and I know they're
probably showing us early missions you
know like especially the one that
heavily focused on Thor when he had the
Donald Blake outfit on yeah I volunteer
sign on it as always awesome the
mechanics of that particular level that
they were showcasing were pretty se me
across the board once you watch him take
down one of those big giant machines and
a few of the hench robots you know you
get what's going on like I felt like I
don't even need to ever block right yeah
thing like that it made me wonder are
you just gonna be like seeing their
button mashing and is the variety mostly
going to be in trying the different
characters out and figuring out who's
play style you like the most or yeah
they're gonna give you some kind of
versatility within each character as
well well the thing with games like this
where a lot of the fun can come in is
not just in the combat if that was all
like the spider-man game was or god of
war because I was thinking of Kratos
when I was watching this yeah you know a
big part of that is figuring stuff out
when you're on the journey the way
you're hopping around missions here I
guess I was a little bit confused and I
wouldn't mind you guys clearing this up
for me I'm not saying this is what it is
I'm asking you to clear it up is there
any of that in the game or is it just
you hop in and you're BAM you're just
fighting no that would be boring for any
game the spider-man angry god of war the
two games that were like popping in my
head is like yeah you know the kind of
when you're fighting a whole bunch of
people you're kind of doing a lot of the
same moves of course it's all the
in-between stuff that makes the combat
feel that much more rewarding and so
what's that in-between stuff like is it
just story mode fight story fight yeah
so what's the journey gonna be like are
you gonna be building the Helicarrier is
it that one moment and Avengers Assemble
where Iron Man's putting it back
together and that's what you're doing in
between the whole time you're just
building stuff man take a break and do
some puzzles and some spatial reasoning
games yeah but the customizations look
like a total blast I really love that
everything they were referencing was
going back to the comic book
inspirations they specifically wanted to
derive each character from and the
amount of like suits you can acquire and
it sounds like most of it is not
online purchasing that a lot of it you
can eventually earn your way to Kamala
Kahn looks awesome there's so much
capitalization on Thor here but I
thought Kamala Khan's abilities look
pretty sweet baby no yeah and they're
like the newest things showcased in the
trailer at least in terms of us being
familiar with the powers and stuff like
that yeah and with MODOK taking the
villain route which is like a lot of
ways a Spider Man have a guy who is like
I'm this way because of the Avengers
using that to give it a more personal
motive and the set up of him is smart
using aim and then building all these
artificial intelligence or robots that
he can control his mind so not exactly a
building that because I opened you up to
a large quantity so you could have a
whole bunch of jakab up stuff going on
throughout the game with all your
Avengers characters you can hop around
with just imagine you could have like a
metal gear Eska moment with Iron Man
where he gets a second line to the suit
then you gotta unplug the controls yeah
be neat and go slow you know like we're
probably gonna see other Avengers
characters that will appear they were
talking about at and he'll how there's a
whole bunch of different people some
people who just don't want to submit to
aim some people who are Inhumans
so I'll probably see other characters
from Marvel that are like superhero
based appear here really what I really
want to see is like it's a bit of a
tease for what the villain fight is like
and to get a clearer idea of what the
adventure could feel like in between all
the cool crazy fun combat stuff yeah cuz
like the difference between this and the
story trailer for me was like this
showcased a lot of the big what felt
like co-op kind of things whereas like
the story trailer did seem like it might
even allow you to start out in a very
contained way as is just Kamala Khan
discovering what's going on with herself
figuring out what position she's in with
aim and then going on this adventure to
find the Avengers and it seems like the
gameplay from there could open up
depending on who you meet and what
storylines you have access to but the
thing that seemed the coolest about this
across the board was just the breadth of
modes you could get into because it
seems like you can if you want to jump
in pick a character and then go and do
some kind of a you know cool mission
it's got the story there if you need it
but if you don't you can plug and play I
know they have like a co-op mode where
like five of you can get together I pick
a character and I to appreciated that
because you
you have specific characters with their
specific personalities you can at least
somewhat customize them to fit your use
of those characters so yeah just as an
experience offering an expansion to you
know this type of game especially I can
definitely see like tons of potential
and yeah the only thing I don't have a
great grasp on is day one you pick this
game up you plug it in where do you
start
yeah what's that gonna feel like I know
what like a big melee match is gonna
feel like and I know what you know the
cutscenes are gonna look like but it
seems like there could be a good amount
of like sneaking stuff you have to do or
a puzzle solving has Kamala Khan what
early what's the exploration element
yeah be like yeah exactly because I love
that getting back into gaming might a
year or two ago like that was something
that I had grew a much bigger
appreciation for it that's why it takes
a long a video game everything crazy
with the exploring partners yeah well
yeah and somebody in the comments of
last video said this and I thought the
same was like I kind of wish this was
some open-world game where I could just
explore all these places for a bit you
know and then get back to avenging yeah
I know it sounds like we're harping on
this and we get to extent we are it
doesn't have to necessarily be like
fully utilize open-world like Red Dead
but something kind of like the Naughty
Dog games like Uncharted or even the
first Last of Us more of that than less
of us to where it's like you can look
around and you could explore some stuff
but it's pretty clear which path you got
to take the whole yeah exploring a it
might bring you something enriching or
something fun or it might waste your
time but yeah it's like a parent that
you can explore some yeah and that's
always a nice option to have I just
don't want this game to only be fun for
like a couple of hours yeah yeah loses
charm and make you not care about
completely so right now I'm like
somewhere between like eighty-five to
ninety percent on everything of in terms
of confidence in what this game will be
like it just seems like whenever they
unveil more it keeps getting better the
last story trailer look the best it's
ever been this game played trailer I
prefer more than the last one we got
however long
oh that was there's gonna be more to
come they set here right oh they're
gonna be releasing a beta or they'll
announce when they'll be releasing a
beta I mean the game comes out in just a
little bit because it's so it comes out
for your birth yeah that's it twenty
twenty or twenty twenty-one hundred
twenty twenty four now one thing I wish
was added in here and this is definitely
an epic cuz this is like this for a lot
of video games when they're doing all
the moves when they're fighting I love
in the voice work when video games go
out of their way to have a bit of that
struggle in their voice when they're
moving around like an intense fight this
is lunging and yeah like as they're
doing their delivery that you could feel
like the struggle and the fight or a
little bit of energy being exerted into
the fight I love when they have that
touch and that doesn't seem present at
all here and that's just one tiny thing
there's I know a lot of games don't do
that and it does seem at least somewhat
important because you know the line
between it feeling like characters in
this situation actually talking and just
you know five people sitting at home
with headsets on yeah that's pretty thin
because of how commonplace that scenario
is they're gonna be online co-op they
said I believe that would be a blast
yeah if you could like team up you know
one of your friends is hope you don't
want Iron Man or one's Black Widow
whatever yeah that would be a total I
mean they're talking about coops it has
to exist in some form it's the future I
feel like there would be no excuse
nowadays especially for as high-profile
property as the Avengers yeah not to let
you remotely get together and do some
ass-kicking cuz they talked about combat
and co-op or you could have like a
finisher move or something yeah yeah or
you can have like a couple that was the
thing I was wondering too is like if you
have an actual co-op going on and you
stun your enemy uh-huh
do you have control over like okay well
you and me let's go over there and
they're stunned finish remove or is that
like a computer thing yeah or whoever
just happens to be nearby yeah
anyway yeah I thought this was a blasted
the video flew by that did not feel like
20-plus minutes that was like a really
quickly spirit it's actually it now it's
pretty into it looks like they're really
bringing their powers and their
abilities to life and the idea of
getting to use the wide variety of cool
powers are not I haven't even been
demonstrated in the movies
feels very very exciting for the
gameplay I'm excited for it this this
actually got me the most excited out of
anyone we've seen this is the one that
got me the most excited so yeah
what do you guys think are you satisfied
do you like it be still apprehensive or
are you leaning more towards the
positives leave your thoughts down below
if you liked our video you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification really get notified I never
got a video up follow us on social media
we mean a hell of a lot we'll catch you
guys soon